well I have to tell you I was very very
happy when I heard it announced that you
were gonna be hosting the BT Awards
Amanda's gonna host but then Amanda's
gonna host during a pandemic and we
can't have large gatherings how does
this work for you like how does this
whole show gonna work now well first of
all you have to see and I'm the cancer
and we just entered cancer season so
shout out to the cancers we are loners
so I get to host the show and I don't
got to do a red carpet I don't gotta
talk to nobody like this is perfect for
a cancer so I'm not trippin at all
they're really I love innovation I love
creativity and that's what this show
really is like leaning into Jim rowdy
rich and all of these artists got to be
given a budget to do their vision of
their song so I think it's really gonna
be a job experience and I don't think it
should be where we're gonna still have a
BT Awards that's at a level of
excellence don't get me wrong like
there's gonna be a difference in the
fact that you're not gonna see that
audience their hair but I think for what
it's worth
you've been in this pandemic for three
months we gotten used to not seeing
audiences there so you know what don't
let that deter you from being the
audience wherever you are okay so you
mentioned the performances and that that
each performers gonna get a budget so
they could like make a music video or do
a performance at home so we don't do we
know what we're gonna get or it could be
just anything it's gonna be a circus
board you know it's gonna be a potpourri
of performances but I think that's what
speaks to black music right then the BT
oryx is giving you all different flavors
from gospel to soul so hip hop the trap
you know so we're going to see that
represented on just another level this
is the 20th anniversary so we're
expecting some hee-haw you know we're
expecting to hit us with something
special so what you got you gonna get
some special we definitely are and
listen it's not just the 20th
anniversary of the awards it's the 40th
anniversary of BT yeah so there's a lot
of history that we are definitely gonna
be packing into the show you know the
streets are asking does it begin with
them B and in with the Yonsei I don't
answer those types of questions I know
your platform Amanda is also too
always amplify black voices so with
everything going on in the world I know
B et is gonna give us something special
but how do you how does the network and
you yourself address where we are in the
state of our nation right now you know
what honestly it's more seamless than I
think people imagined you know for other
networks and other shows it might
require a lot more thought process but
for a black music show black music has
always been intrinsically connected to
what's going on in black lives so we're
seeing artists who are just very
seamlessly and organically bringing in
what's happening in the world into their
performances and I'm doing the same
thing with my comedy and my hosting so
really what we're gonna do is what
exactly is expected of that folks we're
gonna speak and perform from the natural
space where we are right now as black
American folks just want to see
responsibilities taken and actualized
ways not just through like you know
Instagram posts of black squares and
black and white videos of people looking
real serious we want to see some true
measure of a commitment to understanding
that discrimination has been at a core
has been a core piece of the advancement
of all these other groups and still when
we look at Hollywood like you can't shy
away from the fact that like a prejudice
and discrimination racism they are built
into the threads of this tent the
conversations that are being had are
about actualized change and it's it's
got to go beyond just having the
conversations with your black friends
it's got to go beyond just being like no
I'm the cool one it's like there has to
be an actual visual verbal and action
based response and you know and we're
all doing that I always know where your
head is and I always love to listen to
your perspective but where how's your
heart where's your heart right now a lot
of people it's like out of our you know
because I'll be like really excited
about something and happy and then I'll
go to my phone and I'll see another
story of another black person that is
dealing with discrimination in a myriad
of ways from cops to coal did to Karen
though bottom line which is that we
needed to get to this point in order to
get to a better place I hear you I
appreciate you and I cannot wait for the
show
don't get a good time to shine though it
is I know it is I know it's
congratulations this I'm really really
happy for you
[Music]